or whatever and stuff like that and
like that's just not a situation i'd
want to put myself in so when you look
at me do i look like i'm a mother or i
look like i've been divorced no so
basically most of the guys i speak to
it's from okay yeah because it's from
what's
here's the thing every kid minuses you
two points so let's let's let's let's
say let's say let's see
let's do it do we look like mothers i'll
just ask no no
like you can be on like dating apps and
you could look at she's like yeah she's
got a kid like you can tell sometimes
you'll be on you'll be on dating
actually like yeah she's got a kid can
you tell that yeah yeah yeah yeah like
yeah you could i've been working like
you could you could say it's like a
badge of honor that you look like you
don't have one no because i think i mean
like you're you're like you're wearing
it as a badge that i don't look like i
think the point she was trying to make
is if you look at her and she doesn't
look like a mother if a guy approaches
her
you have to tell them and even even as a
woman
yeah but i'm saying even as a girl like
if i hear a guy has kids i'm like skirt
so it's like like even even if i find
him attractive at first i'm 25. okay
yeah see that that changes everything
well it changes for women um but i'm
saying like like men they can't help
they're biologically predispositioned to
not want to put resources into another
guy's kids
like even even in the wild what do they
do when they get the other girl they
kill the cubs
lions literally yeah lions are literally
lions literally do that and look i've
got i've got stepfather like i get it
like i i completely understand it i'm
just saying like
don't
like don't be like oh i don't look like
i've got kids you look like you've got
kids like you look you look a little bit
older and it's not and it's not even
it's not even looking at it from that
standpoint
you're beautiful you're beautiful women
regardless i don't even know why you'd
you'd like to see you know i don't care
that i look like i like i have a child
why would you bring up
she didn't
based on what you said like for like i
said especially doing our pod and stuff
like that i'm very acceptant of my
situation
in the most polite way i don't need you
guys to tell me what i can and cannot
get right because at the end of the day
whether you advise me from today to
tomorrow it's not you i'm going to be
with when it's not you that's going to
get me why when you say what you can and
cannot get what is it that you want what
is it that you want to get could you
like what is it that you want to get one
thing i do know i want is i want to be
happy and i want to be in a realistic
relationship
but i want to be in a realistic
relationship realistically
when guys hear that like oh i want to be
happy it's like no yeah it signals a
lack of loyalty to men because it
basically says like you're going to
leave the second you're not happy
i wouldn't even so anyone that knows me
knows i'm a writer
in a second no go on you go no i just
because you talk a lot on behalf of men
i was just wondering like
do you have loads of breakfast or
something yeah yeah i have five brothers
oh i was wondering
okay yeah like there's a certain way in
which men speak and when you say oh i
want to be happy
one it sounds very vague
and two it sounds like
does happiness change it changes what
people find what people find makes them
happy today may not be what makes it
happen tomorrow so it's like when you
tell me that's why i said what is it
what is it that you want when you say
happiness if if it's the pursuit of
happiness then you could be pursuing
anything and any everything at the same
time so if if you have something that
you want what is it that you want i'd
like to uh yeah because it's hard to
define happiness let's say for example
you've got a man
he takes care of you and your kids yeah
this is your new stepfather you're
married to him yeah he every single
night
you get you get your back blown out it's
beautiful and everything yeah food on
the table
food on the table everything it's the
fact you say it's such an english accent
food on the table everything southeast
london accent
is that enough for happiness
no when it comes to women
i mean yeah wow
it's not what more would you need
because women
women's happiness why are we capping
women's happiness changes all the time
right that's why that's why women are
the ones to initiate the majority of
divorces because they think they know
what they want they get the thing that
they want and then all of a sudden they
don't want it so their happiness and
their minds change constantly so like i
said when a man hears our one happiness
it's like well
what today this week this month this
year and then what's your happiness for
next year so i want to be with someone
who i'm compatible with not just for me
but also for him
i want him to see me as someone that
leaves an impact in his life i don't
want it to just be one-sided like if
he's having a bad day i want him to feel
like let me call grace let's you know go
at this are you looking are you actively
looking for that person uh
yeah i'll say yeah now i am and
you haven't found that person so i'll be
honest like i'm really honest if you
notice um i've met guys that tick all
those boxes
but i'm not going to be that woman
that's going to be oh yeah he's hard
working he's got good money he's this
he's that and just be with him i need to
feel that strong no i need to feel i
need to desire you
so you're telling me yeah it's going to
be a while
you're telling me all of your boxes can
be ticked and you will still say nah i'm
good it sounds you're making it sound
crazy no but you see me it's not like
that
that's how it sounds to me
that's how it sounds because if you if
you ask if you ask men if they'd go on a
second date with a girl that had 80
percent of what she that he wanted
most
yeah yeah most guys answer yes when they
survey they say even if he's not
attracted to him they surveyed if he's
not attracted to her if he had 80
percent of what he wanted men want
attractive women that's like part of it
okay so
all my boxes to get ticked i think
that's unrealistic no but you said
you've dated guys that have all of those
boxes that have the key things
good job money making above average all
of that stuff but i still think there's
something missing but would you okay let
me ask you something would you like to
be how women work on feelings you know
no i think it would come down to
personality
if you take all the boxes but the
personality doesn't matter sorry what
should you like terence i could have
like if if a woman takes all my boxes
but she's a [ __ ] or she's not
respectful
[Music]
how important is that stuff really
but i'm saying i'm saying like in the
old days they didn't do this and they
had better they were more successful if
you look at more traditional countries
where they actually arrange marriages
like they're not talking about
personality and like vibes and that sort
of thing and they have better results
yeah i get it i'm looking for
compatibility i'm looking for i'm i'm
looking for companionship so we need to
finally just need to i'll have to
disagree disagree a little bit with that
one because like let's be serious like
if you marry a psycho
but that's that's an extreme yeah right
but i i i'm right okay don't marry a
psychopath but typically when you get
the families together and they meet each
other you can vet that out right yeah
but i'm saying they weren't in the old
days like
talking about compatibility the way we
do nowadays like a prime example
actually